estou aqui na qualidade do músico
escritor de canções para partilhar
convosco o lugar onde as canções são
feitas quando a música é feita quando o
pensamento é desenvolvido o pensamento
essa coisa qualitativa profunda e chamou
george steiner a poesia do pensamento
aqui todos nós fazemos mas que alimenta
o surgimento alguns não não eu mas
alguns conseguem fazer com o maior
cuidado na oportunidade as palavras que
foram todas inventadas mas que são
colocadas por aquela ordem pensamentos
que formulou a teoria das cordas da
teoria da relatividade o pensamento essa
grande nível mas grande mistério que é
produzido no silêncio da contenção na
confusão no a fugir enquanto enquanto
músico o silêncio como o instrumento
principal da minha actividade
profissional é comum pensar se que o ato
criativo é um ato de inspiração
nós não temos um local bucólico e que
daí qualquer coisa surgirá no momento
divino de inspiração
eu tenho muita pena de desfazer os mitos
pelo menos no iml mas não é ele dava
joão cabral de melo neto dizia que com
alguma razão não coema grande poeta
brasileiro dizia que os dois atos
humanos mais precisos e mais feios são
criar e de ficar alguma razão assiste
joão cabral de melo neto é que é que o
ato criativo num ato bonito não é um ato
romântico inspiracional não é um raio
livino fulminou o criador
os é uma fórmula matemática uma madre
iva vida física uma sinfonia uma
composição o romance um poema
o que é verdade é que a criação é pra lá
em ser fruto de muito trabalho é
remetendo para as palavras de joão
cabral neto uma vez mais é excluído tudo
aquilo que foi absorvido da criação
aquela que vem do nada porque essa
tecnologia da palavra criação é fazer
nada e não há nada que seja mais
imaterial o silêncio eo pensamento é
fazer destes dois elementos algo nessa
reclusão de silêncio nesta audição de
silêncio fazer algo necessita de um
outro instrumento que é o pensamento eo
pensamento é um jogo inimá tico
assinados relações daquilo que fomos
daquilo que valemos daquilo que chamamos
daquilo que nos frio daquilo que fizemos
aquilo que tínhamos essa mágoa manhã que
falou que é o pensamento
isso tudo se conjuga naquele espaço
naquele momento de reclusão para a
produção de algo novo e essa é um ato
criativo o ato criativo é o vomitar
intelectual daquilo que foi o impacto
aumento absurdo e vivenciado obviamente
como dizia jorge luis borges
nós somos os livros colhemos as mulheres
queimadas
a música é uma das formas de quebrar o
silêncio
nem sempre a música não só naquilo que é
subjetivamente discutível na estética a
quem gosta de determinado estilo de
música que gosta do outro há quem goste
de mim aqui nós o que é bom porque
sempre que gosta da gente gosta de uma
pessoa é porque ela me viu estava morta
e portanto esta é a música diziam
palavra dada subjetividade estética
muito prováveis desse debate
a música pode ser ruído e oeste segundo
definição da organização mundial de
saúde tudo aquilo que não é solicitado
tudo aquilo que perturba o nosso
descanso por turma o nosso momento por
tudo a nossa vivência e que o cérebro
tem problema em mma e permanentemente
nós estamos eliminar o ruído das nossas
vidas
estamos a eliminar música das nossas
ps só que se faça um passeio teórico
comigo agora por todo entramos num táxi
está o rádio ligado
entramos nos mercados está a música
ligada vamos comprar umas calças amorosa
está a música aliada sempre um risco
trocar o aeroporto na casa de banho os
pashtuns de nasi há permanentemente um
bombardear constantes de música
informação de som que pode ser excelente
mas naquele momento não foi solicitado e
por isso o nosso cérebro fatiga vá ao
longo do dia
perguntem aos empregados que trabalham
nas caixas dos supermercados se gostam
da música ambientes como lhe chamam os
seus empregadores
aquela que é utilizada para reforçar a
comprar rápido ea comprar pressa ou as
empregadas os empregados que estão nas
lojas de roupa com música back to noite
dia todo o dia todo dia nos centros
comerciais a perguntar se aquilo
realmente a música os prémios aquele
ruído e aqui nesta equação não estética
não é estética é da presença não
desejada da música nas nossas vidas
nesta equação poderá entrar ainda o
fator mais trágico é que
para além de não permitir tal inclusão
que eu dizia da audição nós pra nós
próprios do usufruto nós pronto mundo
devemos as coisas como queremos ver sem
citarmos banda sonora nós não precisamos
que nos imponham banda sonora nós
construímos
eu não preciso ir à praia para uma
esplanada tomar um café e ter música em
cima de mim não precisa eu quero ver o
mar e as crianças longe a brincar é isso
que eu quero ver
eu posso e pra longe do café mas
problema que não levam a nada que eu
quero ao fundo mas há situações muito
piores do que essa
vou dar alguns exemplos prisão não
presentes em menor hoje são realidade é
relatado por alguns sobreviventes dos
campos de concentração que nos caso o
combóio que parava em lyon o lyon foi um
centro terminantes para a deportação de
judeus franceses espalhados estavam por
toda aquela zona e foram distribuídos
por vários campos atualização do office
boy carnaval de final
muitos lados sobreviventes depois
citados por alguns que foram
encarregados de passar esta quadra
diziam que o cowboy parava na estação do
lyon
a estação mundial curiosamente era perto
do conservatório e havia um oficial das
ss que gostava muito de deve-se e tocava
disse que deve ser um grande compositor
francês um imenso êxito financeiro
profissional
127 min e que não teve culpa se utilizar
dessa maneira como o resto não tiver
outro jeito casa deve-se enquanto que os
combóios cheios dos deputados que
estavam é padecer de fome frio nem
certeza ficarão três quatro dias na
estação parada da chuva ao segmento
houve até 2011 o programa mostrará isto
música mostrar uma banda sonora do
inferno
pior ainda nos próprios campos de
concentração
os nazis tinham orquestras cortadas
entre os músicos
geralmente não judeus porque nem sequer
subiu hoje 0 permite tocar só numa fase
posterior isso aconteceu portanto
músicos presidente polaco sobretudo não
judeus presença de comunistas e sabiam
tocar instrumentos e havia várias
orquestras nos campos de atuação modesta
feminina máster masculina
essas orquestras tinham por função tocar
enquanto que os prisioneiros iam para o
trabalho
restavam trabalho eo para as câmaras de
gás ou em discussões ou então ao então
pior ainda não sei se alguma coisa pior
do que isto para entreter os próprios
nazis num bordel que existe nomeadamente
em auschwitz e claro que tocavam os
grandes compositores clássicos placa do
carro bitoun claro que estávamos antes
claro que ao mostrar aos claro que o
aumento queriam wagner uma vez mais eu
pergunto para quem ouvia seria a música
isto seria uma tortura uma forma
insidiosa do inferno
portanto não é estética que está em
causa é a ausência de podermos viver a
nossa vida com a banda sonora que
quisermos construir
eu recentemente em paris estava em paris
quando foram os atentados nestes últimos
atentados que tenhamos um espetáculo na
sexta-feira que os atentados foram uma
outra etapa e eu sei a rua na qual os
dias devem calcular a syrah
transfigurou-se cidade não era a cidade
que eu tenha conhecido e fui a um dos
meus locais favorito e eu não sou um
homem de fé
o que não quer dizer que não seja um
homem espiritual e fui a nota da tam que
o local de história da arte e da cultura
saber do conhecimento é também um
um local de meditação do do pensamento
de intensidade intensidade dramática é
um sítio onde eu consigo vir a mim
próprio não é só no trabalho em qualquer
sítio qualquer tempo e época
por fim são os próprios mesmo local da
explosão para que possamos ouvir o
silêncio por dentro
e nesses dias no hati no adro enfrenta a
catedral do atleta atualmente todos
vocês conhecem o grande ato em frente à
casa noturna estava vazio
ao ponto de o ter jogado que que tudo
estava fechada
as únicas pessoas no adro eram militares
no treinador e paris
despida dos turistas despida da vida que
tem país aspira da banda sonora que
pareça é inspirada do riso inspira das
falas
essa sim é a verdadeira banda sonora que
pode ser ruim mas que não é música
porque a música é também um beijo e um
abraço
música é presença num sítio música é o
silêncio e naquela nota relata vazia
eu entrei na na catedral estava a ver um
serviço muito emocionado deserto
turistas via só os fiéis não sendo fiel
cumpre há alguma alguma discrição e
apenas ouvir porque estava a ser
interpretada música dos grandes madruga
listas renascentistas entre os quais
jorge candel pé de homem baixou durante
cerca de uma hora eu tive um dos
momentos mais belos da minha vida com
música que eu não tinha vivido mas quem
treinamento precisava muito e era este
espaço silêncio
a audição das nossas próprias idéias de
fruição de fruição do retorno a 1
o local ano nós possamos aos contarmos a
nós próprios a escutar a volta é um
espaço onde nós temos permanentemente
sujeitos à tirania
a intuição as informação
a pseudo a informação aquilo que leva o
entrosamento da divindade das popstars
dos artistas do rock das supermodelos
dos masters sete dos atores e atrizes
os futebolistas do da identificação da
permanente a identificação do indivíduo
não porto faz mas porque parenta ser em
concurso permanente de televisão numa
deriva que seria muito difícil de evitar
uma deriva em que têm treinamento do
sucesso como a máxima façanha da
humanidade
este treinamento midiático em que
permanentemente ocupar os ecrãs das
televisões as redes sociais vão
bombardear permanentemente com as suas
fotografias da sua feição da sua ida ao
café da piscina dos seus pés no chão
seja do fundo do céu e este treinamento
do dia mais tarde ou mais cedo
figuras como dono o trânsito fica vagão
não iria e político da reposição da
justiça social de vencer as intrigas
sociais mas que se impõe por sua
capacidade de dominar os meios de
comunicação social sem qualquer sei que
nós possamos ter qualquer palavra a
dizer nesta não ser desligada e este
entrosamento dentro do discurso muito
bem e chamou o eterno regresso do
fascismo é muito mais fácil vencer pelo
discurso do óbvio
o discurso que diz que judeus são
compatriotas pela crise ou execução
imigrantes
os migrantes e que os lugares extra que
há pessoas ilegais são os culpados pela
crise bancária na europa pela crise
financeira é muito mais fácil o discurso
do que o discurso da construção um
discurso que ataca 10
o grande mal da sociedade a assimetria
social a pobreza ea desigualdade
crean teria terminado dizendo apenas que
e um do assunto do momento que é
fundamental uma certa acese um certo
tiro o cetro fuso
o silêncio é claramente um sítio a
literatura o conhecimento a ciência à
arte são formas de silêncio só forma de
enriquecimento interior e eu creio que é
possível a construção do pensamento de
uma forma coletiva
não há identificação com os padrões da
medíocre da identificação com os padrões
da sabedoria e da compaixão da bondade e
do futuro
muito obrigado